all right I am to misbehave okay so in
going through the the joss whedon stuff
that I wish to go through I've already
touched on both the best and worst
episodes of both Buffy and Angel now
when I talk to Firefly I had to
basically do that all in one go
cuz there's so few episodes that I just
ranked the whole thing so instead since
I don't have a worst episodes of Firefly
to be able to do I'm instead going to
talk about something that I touched on
ever so slightly in that list before
which is my major hang-up and problem
with the film serenity and that has to
do with the operative now this is not
the only problem I have with this film
but it's the one that I can't get over
it some of the other stuff that I don't
love
I can accept as storytelling decisions
that aren't to my preference like the
fact that we get a background and an
explanation of the Reavers I don't think
that was worth the mystery of them being
sacrificed because I don't think the
answer is as interesting or makes them
any scarier but that stuff that I can go
that was the decision they made okay not
what I would have done but fine what
they do with the operative though I feel
that that just doesn't work now it's not
the character as a whole I actually
really like the character this was the
first film I ever saw to Attell Ejiofor
in and he's great I started going I need
to watch for what else this guy does cuz
he's really good in this part and the
character is engaging in he's he's
really fascinating because he's fighting
for a Cause that he knows he can't see
the benefits of I love the
back-and-forth between him and mal over
those monitors after mal has you know
found what he did to where we're book
was and you know he explains I'm a
monster the world that I'm tried to
create I'm not gonna get to live in it
are you are you nuts
you know I that's fascinating to me I
found him incredibly compelling as a
character however
it seems like the film got a little over
infatuated with him because he lives he
doesn't die he doesn't get killed and
it's not that I necessarily needed the
character to die but it is not just that
the film allowed him to live the
character of Malcolm Reynolds allowed
him to live so let's look back a little
bit at Malcolm Reynolds what was
established about him throughout the run
of Firefly he has no qualms about
killing people this is not a Batman
situation where man if he just killed
his enemies his life would be so much
easier no he does when it's the best
option he will do it and there's a
moment that even within this film that
captures that really really well when he
goes to get an ara and the operatives
there and the operative says I'm unarmed
and mal just goes good and shoots him
good guy was wearing body armor so he
lived but like that
that's Malcolm Reynolds right there and
that's without even severe personal
motivation on top of that which by the
end of the movie he has he has in spades
because he's lost people by that point
he lost wash he lost book who died as a
direct result of the operative himself
for all they know the operative was the
one who killed him and there was also
all the other people there implied to
include children and we know there were
a ton of people that are dead because of
this man and yet Malcolm doesn't kill
him this is a man who kicked a
villainous chrony into the intake engine
of his ship because he annoyed him and
he allows this man to live now I
understand the thinking behind what it
tried to do because the
the end for the operative that it goes
for as opposed to killing him is to
break his faith which is what he'd been
fighting for up to that point and I'm
not saying mal wouldn't have done that
you know by chaining the guy down and
playing for him the information that
they got from Miranda so he learns you
know what it was that they were trying
to share with the with the universe as a
whole that mal would want him to see
that and understand the falsehood that
he was fighting for but I still don't
buy that mal would let him live in
addition to that so like first of all I
have trouble buying that this is enough
to break the guy's spirit in the first
place like like because you can look at
this thing and what the Alliance did and
you can go that definitely didn't work I
bet they probably won't try that again
and while you again you can make an
argument look somebody will try it again
and that would probably even be valid
this is one of those cases it's it's
really hard when films tried to have a
villainous character suddenly lose faith
in their cause because they only usually
only have time to give them one singular
piece of information go and now your
faith is shattered and I'm sorry people
with that level of commitment don't have
their world shattered in an instant by
one piece of information they don't even
if it shakes them it's gonna take time
to process and everything else so I
don't really buy that in the first place
and then you know like I said mal not
killing him after he defeats him in
combat that doesn't work I understand
there's a slight logistic thing because
the operative had to be around to tell
his other people to stand down okay all
of that might not warrant a video of me
getting really irritated about it except
they had to have the operative come back
at the end and have one more scene with
mal which not only is taking away from
letting us live and understand and see
the impact of the dead characters that
this film killed off to give us more
time with the villain who should be dead
this feels like a slap in the face and
if I don't buy that mouth didn't kill
him before you know in mr. universes a
little broadcast engine room whatever it
was I really don't buy that he what that
man walk away a second time no no and
it's not a matter of like oh well the
operatives not a threat anymore
think about what Batman did think about
what he did think mom who he killed mal
is just gonna let that guy walk away at
that point especially because the man
himself says that you know he's not
really the the alliance's man anymore so
they probably won't care if he dies it's
becomes consequence-free
you're telling me mal was not gonna just
shoot the guy in the bag and said leave
him with the warning I better not see
you again what no shoot him kill him now
what is wrong with you and that is a
major nitpick issue I have with a film
that well not perfect i overall enjoy
and a character who I like a lot but
just dammit man and so that's something
in this film that is otherwise pretty
enjoyable for me that just drives me
nuts am i over analyzing yes of course I
am it's nitpick grants but in any case
your thoughts on this or about the film
serenity in general some poof some folks
gave you the thoughts when I did the
list but obviously this is more targeted
towards that so whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it
chuck me a buck on patreon and all the
other stuff links for all that and more
is down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]